you know i i commend you on something a
lot of celebrities show up in the
tabloids all the time the paparazzi
photos of them misbehaving i never see
you ever and then recently i stumbled on
this you're
the least cool paparazzi snap
ever
ever
what's the story there i had just had a
big lunch apparently
i
uh yeah that's a i'm kind of a toilet
paper connoisseur and uh that's that's
charmin ultra strong as you can see
which uh
good it's a good toilet paper yeah
ultra strong is the best one it is a
good toilet paper i'm trying to get free
toilet i don't know why i'm trying to
get free because i don't want another
picture like that taken that's why i
want free toilet paper yeah please send
it to me please you have to go out and
get it but uh why why is toilet paper so
important i think my dad was always
really finicky about his toilet paper uh
so much so my parents live in canada and
actually in canada the toilet paper
rolls are a quarter of an inch more
narrow than here in america and so i
actually have to smuggle him toilet
paper
across the border every time i uh i go
from here to back to vancouver
and i just saying it now i don't know if
it's illegal i really have no idea
what's up well
they're gonna they're gonna pat you down
next time yeah exactly and i stick it
all up my butt which is right
[Music]
but now they have the x-rays now they
got the
x-rays a lot of time cuts out
exactly
cut out the middle man
well that toilet paper again is charming
ultra strong ultra strong
i'm told you just had a meeting with one
of the great filmmakers of all time
george lucas you had a meeting that
george lucas was at i don't i i it was
amazing you know and as an actor you get
to do things that as a kid you would
never think you got to do but yeah i met
with joe i met with steven spielberg and
he came into the meeting with george
lucas and uh i was so excited as a nerd
you know and i'm like you know what do
you talk what's george lucas going to
talk about and what he talked about was
how he actually thinks that the world is
going to end in the year 2012
like for real and like the whole time
i'm thinking like is he joking like he
is he kind of seems like he's joking and
then i slowly realized like he's not
joking like he really thinks the world i
made a joke like good thing skywalker
ranch is on the other side of the fault
line he's like it is a good thing that
skywalker is
like
otherwise i'd be falling into the ocean
with the rest of the west the western
seaport and uh and honestly the whole
time i was thinking like this is insane
a and b if you're george lucas and you
think this is true there's no way you
don't have a millennium falcon somewhere
yes
that's like full of fuel just ready to
go and so i said to him like can i get a
seat on your millennium falcon should
the time come and he said no i don't
have a millennium falcon but i think
that's bs and there's no way that he
doesn't have more
because he's george lucas so you really
think he's telling the truth i believe
anything george lucas says about space
period i think
if george lucas tells me one thing and
stephen hawking tells me something
directly conflicting it i'm going with
george lucas
he's your space authority period
that is the right call exactly now
speaking of space let's talk about this
this new movie paul yes now paul it's a
good idea for a movie paul is the name
of an alien it is i i it's about two uh
nerds who are uh doing a road trip
across america and they discover an
alien uh who is played by me who and i
kind of use them to to get me across the
country so i can i can go back to my
home planet
and uh it's amazing the technology you
know it's all like performance capture
it's like the same stuff they used to do
avatar but uh it's applied to jokes
about private parts and marijuana usage
which uh
i think it's about time but someone uh
it's the appropriate use of that
technology i believe
we we have a clip here from paul let's
take a look
[Applause]
sorry
i just had to see that again
in fact i want that to be the clip we
show every time for every clip if
harrison ford's out here let's take a
look at that powerful performance
now let's take a clip
look at a real clip of paul
a you an alien
to you i am yes are you going to probe
us
why does everyone always assume that
what am i doing am i harvesting farts
how much can i learn from an ass well
wha
i'm sorry what's your name it's graham
willie and what's his name uh that's the
writer clive gollings okay cool i'm paul
paul
yeah it's a nickname that's stuck i my
ship crashed on a dog it doesn't matter
look if you don't help me i could die on
this road tonight okay okay perfect
great okay help me help me grab them
this man's peed his pants
[Applause]
why not exactly
why can't there be an alien named paul
well paul opens
uh march 18th make sure you're going to
see that and where are you going to be
in 2012 when that day hits were you i'm
going to be camped out outside skywalker
ranch just
praying
take us with you george
you know the whole building he's going
to press the button and the whole
building's going to start to transition
exactly it's just going to turn
off the whole thing goodbye everybody
just to hedge our bets i think we should
sit in a canoe